si les parisiens se plaignent de la
saleté chez de l'insécurité dans le
métro à tokyo les japonais souffrent
d'une fréquentation impressionnante il
faut dire que 60% des tokyoïtes se
déplace en métro et en train
jean-jacques bazié et pierre brasse
caisses ont rencontré un professeur de
français
monsieur quito ils passent plus de trois
heures par jour dans le métro l'un des
plus peuplés du monde
regardez à 62 ans congo quito à la
démarche a l'air il vaut mieux car à
tokyo prendre le métro relève de
l'exploit sportif dans cette gare
centrale à shinjuku se croisent chaque
jour deux millions de personnes pour
beaucoup un supplice qui dure en moyenne
deux heures par jour deux fois plus que
pour un parisien pour chrome bokito ces
mêmes trois heures de transport pour
aller et revenir à l'université de tchô
à 30 km de son domicile
je pense que c'est 300 ans avant d'en
libérer au travail vieux super pratique
c'est sur cet état de stress n'est pas
rare
selon une enquête réalisée par
l'université auprès d'hommes de 40 à 60
en passant plus d'une heure et demie
dans le métro il est prouvé qu'il
souffrirait plus que les autres de
troubles visuels de pertes de mémoire et
de courbatures
les trains qui s'y sent très pratique
ils arrivent à l'heure le seul problème
c'est qu'ils sont trop bons des très
très fatigant
sont extrêmement pénible et parfois j'ai
envie d'exprimer ma colère tellement
j'en ai marre lors d'une correspondance
congo quitos autorise toujours une pause
cigarette dans l'espace autorisé
règlement respecté par tous car dans ce
métro sur vendée va vers ce hameau
mètres carrés chacun a bien compris que
la discipline était le seul moyen
d'arriver à bon port et d'éviter la
catastrophe
on doit faire l'acteur
monsieur qu'est ce qu'on s'habille à un
sap donc fait commandeur s'est faite en
prenant de bon sens en surface la
situation n'est guère plus enviable
pourtant seulement 23% des tokyoïtes
utilisent leur voiture
c'est trois fois moins qu'à paris mais
suffisant pour provoquer des
embouteillages morts le réseau routier
est complètement inadapté ou une ville
de 12 millions d'habitants
un véritable casse tête pour le
gouvernement il a imaginé un projet de
périphérique
mais son espoir vient de ce nouveau
centre de gestion de la circulation 200
caméras filment l'ensemble de trafic et
les policiers peuvent intervenir sur les
feux tricolores dans treize mille
carrefour
ce système a permis de faire diminuer
les bouchons de 8 à 10%
mais peu de gens s'en sont rendu compte
et les insultes n très souvent mais
c'est comme ça donc on accepte
bon on ne peut accepter parce que sinon
on ne prenait pas dit à tokyo alors
curieusement dans ce pays de haute
technologie c'est l'un des moyens de
locomotion le plus simple qui fait
fureur la bonne vieille bicyclette une
pour deux habitants la chaussée leur est
interdit elle roule donc sur les
trottoirs
un exemple à ne pas suivre à paris